Hurricane Mitch hit Nicaragua in 1998.
Almost 4,000 people were just wiped out and drowned in central
Nicaragua. And Mike Wall led a team down there,
and that's where he first met Dees And Dees lives in the foreign northern
part of Nicaragua, almost to the Honduran border in a town called.
And he had grand plans and a grand vision for church planting
and for a seminary.
Most of those early trips were medical trips. Typically,
the EZ or his network of pastors saw that there was a need or a,
a community that did not have a church. We would take a medical team in,
and at the end of the clinic,
the believers would come in, uh,
share the gospel with all those people that had been seen in the clinic that
day,
Through that proclamation of the gospel and people's response,
then planning a church, providing them with a pastor to lead that group.
And then as that group would grow and flourish and continue,
if it was sustained, then we would go in and,
and provide a building for that group to meet in.
And then that would propel their ministry more and more.
And then typically we would take a construction crew down led by Caleb McKay,
build a four wall cinder block type of building.
Over the course of the years,
Henderson Hills has probably been responsible for at least 25 to 30
of those church plants.
One of the next projects that Deez really needed in San Mateo was a
faith-based medical clinic. So we decided that, um,
we would try to come alongside and do in ministries of Jesus Nicaragua.
In 2012,
we sent Stephanie Egert and Jamie Nicks to Santio to
basically help finish the construction of ministries of Jesus.
In May of 2013, we actually had the ribbon cutting.
And M O j Nicaragua opened its doors for the first time to give
care body, soul, and spirit, much like we do right here in Edmond.
Uh, somewhere close to 2013, 2014,
as a church and as a missions department,
really thought it was important to start raising up business leaders or
businesses overseas.
We really wanted to go to reach Muslim believers,
whether that be in Europe or in North Africa.
And we felt like it was easiest to try and start doing a business in
Nicaragua first, develop the business plan and then branch out from there. Uh,
so around 2013, 2014, we chose mate gpa.
One of the neatest parts of presence,
or our platform in Monte GPA is what's called the A L C or the Academy
of Language and Culture. So it started with the Stinsons.
They moved to Alpa.
The Lord provided a building to rent and then a house close by that they could
live in. And they started the work of starting a language academy.
Tom and Brenda Shively were instrumental in curriculum development,
business planning from the very beginning.
And then the stensons were the boots on the ground.
We were able to have teachers go from Henderson Hills for as short as a week or
two, and as long as a year or two,
we got the opportunity to build a relationship on that platform of a language
school. And so that was started in 20 13, 20 14,
and has continued on to today. And,
and out of the a l C has birthed an a language institute in North Africa.
One of the other visionary things that Edes wanted to do was
start an official seminary in and around Sania. For years,
he and his, uh,
pastors had raised up young men to teach and preach
in so many of these small villages or communities and churches were built.
But he really wanted more of a formalized education.
Somewhere around 2017, uh, this was started in Someo.
The members of Henderson Hills have completely raised all monies for
that so that every student that goes through there on a two year, um,
educational track is fully funded. You know,
almost a hundred pastors had formal training that is now
recognized by the Nicaraguan Baptist Association.
So many times we think about partnering with a local church so that we can build
their ministry.
And one thing that we discovered being a part of Mi Glacia Batista in
Alpa was that they had so much ministry going on already that churches also
partnered with in those days, two other,
and now three other church plants in the area,
in other communities that are maybe 30 minutes in either direction to go
and share the gospel and plant churches and grow those churches.
And one way that we saw that happen was in a community called Keda Onda.
That community had a fellowship of believers that had been pretty small.
And throughout that year, we continued to evangelize in that community,
continued to share and to pray for that community. And they had,
they had had a little structure built. It was a roof and a slab.
And one of their, one of their goals, one of their visions was to,
to construct a building. And so partnering with Caleb McKay and,
and some of his guys were able to come together and, and we had a really,
really neat trip where we, where we built a building.
We have seen that bear fruit in that community in the years since.
You think it's not a building and the church isn't a building,
but having some place for them to meet and gather and home base, uh,
so to speak, has really propelled ministry even in that community.
We're open to what the Lord will do,
continue and continue to plant churches in and around Alpa in around Santio.
So we see that him continuing to, to grow this out and so that the,
the churches that we've had a part in planting by God's grace then
continue to have a calling to do the same down the road in that next community
down the road. So our prayer is that Santa Amelia,
as they grow and flourish,
will feel a calling to go to that next community down the road in San Ramon.
And that as the Lord continues to provide ministry leaders to come through our
seminary,
that they're equipped to go to those communities that they feel called and they
feel equipped because we know that it makes way more sense for a
Nicaraguan who speaks the language,
who knows the culture to be trained and then go into one of these communities
than it does for somebody like me.
Good morning church. Uh, my name's t r Lewis.
And it's a pleasure to be here this morning with you all celebrating Nicaragua
and all the work that God has done. Praise God. Praise God.
And it, it's a pleasure to introduce to you my friend, uh,
pastor Javier Moraga and Marcos Hernandez. So, uh,
Javier was the, the, is the pastor of Premier cia, Baptista,
which is in Alpa First Baptist Church, ALPA,
which is where my family and I worshiped. He was our pastor for a year.
And during that year, we didn't have the opportunity to have a translator.
So you guys have Marcos to translate, uh, for him this morning. We, we,
that was part of our learning of Spanish was, was under Pastor Moraga. And,
but over the years, God has knit our family together in a very special way.
It's created relationships where our daughter, Emma,
went and lived with his family,
with their family for six weeks and their daughter Azalea has come and,
and lived with our family for a time. And just seeing the,
the kingdom grow and, and then for, for God to,
uh, connect our hearts, uh, and, and,
and ministry for the kingdom has really blessed my life. So I'm,
I'm excited that we're all getting to hear from Pastor Moraga this morning,
and then we'll also hear more this afternoon.
So I'd love to pray for these brothers as we open God's word together.
Father God, you are so good to us.
You have blessed this church.
You've blessed Nicaragua and you've given us a relationship,
a relationship that's, and, and a unity that's based in you,
that's founded in you, that's given by your spirit. And so Father,
we pray that that would be a testimony to the world,
that this partnership, this, this amta, this relationship,
father, that, that you've,
you've given us together is a reflection of the relationship that we have with
you in love and in grace. So Father, this morning as we open your word together,
as Pastor Javier walks us through your word,
may our hearts be open to the ways that you might call and speak this morning.
It's in Jesus' name that we pray. Amen.
Thank
You brother Thomas and tr and thank you for all the congregation and for
participating in this celebration.
I would like to start by reading the scripture in the book of John chapter 20,
verse 19 through 21.
And it says, on the evening of that first day of the week,
when the disciples were together with the doors locked for
fear of the Jews, Jesus came and stood among them and said,
peace be with you. After He, after he has said this,
he showed them his hands.
And inside the disciples were overjoyed when they saw the Lord
again, Jesus said, please be with you. As the Father has sent me.
I am sending you,
I mean
This part where God says,
just as God has sent me the same way I send you,
this is one part I really like.
Before we continue,
I would like to start with a word of congratulations to all of you,
Pastor.
I would like to congratulate the church, Henderson Hills, our pastor,
the elders, and all the leadership
Pastor.
'cause it's been a wonderful and a big blessing just to be through all these
25 years planting churches and, uh, training leaders
Is,
And it is more than wonderful everything that has happened in this last 25
years.
And that reminds me that word where he says, because for him and by him,
all things are done.
Congratulations
Church.
And the second thing is also I would like to thank
Bueno
Our God is wonderfully, wonderfully good.
And the same words that our brother ti said.
My name, my name is J We are, uh,
pastoring the First Baptist Church in Mat.
And
I'm happily marry with my wife, which she's with us this morning,
and our daughter Ella, which she was singing this, uh, a little bit ago.
And we have two other sons, which are serving back then in Nicaragua, in Mat.
And many of you have already been there and know the church in Mat.
And I wish every one, every single one of you would be with us in Mat
Cafe. We
Would like, I would like to enjoy a delicious cup of coffee with a OSA
Pastor Mike Wall.
We wanna thank also Brother Mike Wall for his family and his ministry.
S
For the courage that our brother ti had to travel to Nicaragua and live with us
for one year.
And for all the rest of you that have been there and have traveled,
thank you so much for, um, being with us and helping us develop this,
this work.
The most wonderful thing is to have that connection with God.
And by the glory of God, we have, um,
at least 30 years serving in Mat.
Just like the Apostle Paul said,
I praise God for he has given me this ministry.
And I would like to go back to this scripture once again to speak about what it
says because the purpose of this morning is not to talk about us,
but to talk about him.
There's many texts in the Bible that speak to us about the plans that God has.
And one of the things is that because we are able to get together and sing these
uh, songs and worship God is just because God is good.
You have
Been blessed by the Lord.
You
Have a wonderful praise and worship team,
and you have a wonderful weather. It is a little bit cold for us,
but wonderful weather.
And Jeremiah say, well, the plans that I have for you are for good,
not for evil.
And the greatest plan that God has had for humanity is to send his only son
Jesus Christ, for the salvation of all of us
And
All of us. We have heard of the redemption plan of God, how he has saved us
Grand Commission.
And there's many texts in the Bible that speak to us about that great commission
Because
We've been blessed because God is already with us,
The name of Amelia, we have family, we have work,
We have many things.
But
The most wonderful thing we have is the presence of God in our hearts.
The the greatness and the strength of a family is not what they have.
It
Is not the scientific knowledge that we could have.
Is not anything to do with the material possessions that we could have.
It is the presence of God in our hearts.
And Jesus Christ has commissioned the church
so that we can share with other people.
An example, Matthew chapter 28, Marco
Mark,
Chapter 16,
chapter 24, John
21, 1
Corinthians chapter nine.
And
We can continue reading scripture after scripture of the things that we know God
wants us to do.
And that is to share Christ with all the people.
Gloria,
We praise God for all the things, the material things that we received.
But
All these things, all those things will disappear.
The presence of God is forever in our hearts
Is
The life that God gives is life eternal.
The context of this text
is the death of our Lord Jesus Christ.
The image that disciples had,
it's an image of sadness
that Jesus that was doing miracles,
That
Jesus that was healing the sick,
that Jesus that come down this, the, the storm
has died.
This is the first day of the week,
and that's what this text says.
And in that same day, Jesus appeared to the disciples
that Jesus that was dead. Now he's alive.
And the first thing that we can see on this verses is the joy of the disciples.
The
Disciples were happy.
And that's what happens when you are in the presence of God.
In I, in
The presence of God. There's plenty, plenty of joy
when we come to the lore. Our lives are transformed.
There's a story on the chapter of Mark chapter five that says that a man was
very, very sick.
A man that lived in the cemetery.
And when Jesus got to that place where this man was,
Jesus Christ had an encounter with this man and he transformed and changed his
life.
And when this man has been transformed by the power of God,
Jesus,
These men wanted to stay with Jesus.
But
Jesus told these words,
AMI, go to
Your people, to your family and tell them
and tell them how great things God has done with you.
He has mercy on you.
And
That's what God has done with every one of us.
And that encounter where Jesus Christ has resurrected,
the disciples are so joyful.
Pass our so.
And Jesus said this word, peace be with you.
He blessed be the Lord because he is our peace.
He
Also said, my P the p my peace, I gave you my my peace.
You will have.
And that is because when we're under the lore, we have peace.
And that's a great blessing that every Christian in every part of the world,
we can trust in the peace of God.
There's
A verse in the book of visa, Isaiah chapter 26, verses three and four,
that is very important for you and for me
To gu
You will keep imperfect peace to him that perseveres in you
because he has trust in you.
And we need to trust God because in him,
we have the strength of of God in our lives.
And we also see in this verse how the,
the work of God in the person of Jesus Christ also does. He says he,
my father has sent me
Romantic.
And that's a declaration that is not a really romantic declaration.
It's a powerful declaration,
It's
A lifestyle.
Jesus Christ came to this world with a very specific purpose.
And that was to redeem this world.
There's
A verse that we can read and we'll ask you to open your bibles in the book of
Colossians.
And we're gonna read Colossians chapter one verses 16,
chapter one, verse 16.
And the verse says,
for by him all things were created, things in heaven and on earth,
visible and invisible.
Whether thrones or powers or rulers or authorities,
all things were created by him and for him.
And this is a glorious declaration.
And this glorious declaration is manifested on that encounter between Jesus
Christ and his disciples.
And the thought that we have,
we need to keep in our minds is that as he has sent me, so I send you
now, the Lord is sending us each one of us.
And I think there's a few elements that we need to consider that God gives us as
a family, as a church.
And the first thing is that when we go, we go based on the word of God.
Gloria,
Glory to God for this wonderful book,
The
Word of God for us
and all the Christians that understand that God is calling us to a mission.
We have to base that on the word of God.
One Timothy chapter three, lemme open that for you.
One Timothy chapter three verses
At this time there's a man where God has, uh, a sign,
a wonderful man, uh, this, this advice and has tell him this advice.
Chapter one,
although I hope to come to you soon,
I am writing to you this instructions so that if I I'm delay,
you will know how people ought to conduct themselves in God's household.
And
This is one more reason why we need to base our life in the word of God.
God senses us in spite of our age.
I can see over here we have all ages, John, people, adults,
elder people,
and God has no problem to involve every one of you in his plan
of mission.
God calls older people like Moses and uh,
Abra
and God calls young people like Jeremiah
And
God call all very different for different from different backgrounds with
different life stories.
But
Also God call us to prepare ourselves for that mission.
What
Is that preparation that we must have? We need to prepare yourself
With prayer. With prayer
On the reading of the scripture,
my beloved brothers,
the mission that the church has is to proclaim the gospel of Jesus Christ.
And
We need to be fundamentally based on this scripture.
It doesn't matter what our age is
and to prepare ourselves in this wonderful book.
Many times we dedicate time in many other things.
We can spend hours and hours doing other tasks,
But
God is waiting for us that we may participate on this mission.
I'm going to this live and this mission consecrating our lives. For this is
Jesus Christ. When he was praying for the church and his disciples, he said,
sanctify them. Sanctify them in your word.
My beloved brother, we have been blessed, we have been sanctified.
We have been called to live a life for him
And
God is calling us so that we can go and do this work in love.
And Paul says also that even though we are sin, as cry, die for us
And
Blessed be the name of the Lord.
And let me kind of tell you a little bit of, um, um,
tell you what Nicaragua really is.
Nicaragua
A few words. We are the, uh, Baptist Convention in Nicaragua,
328 churches
and they're organized in 12 regions.
And we are the north central region. That's where we are located.
And there's three cities within that region.
The area of mat,
We
Have 13 smaller cities
and that part of has 600,000, uh,
around 600,000. Uh, Hess,
the city has more than 200,000
and we only have three churches in the city of Mat.
And there's another, uh, city where there's other two churches.
However, there's many other places within that area that there's no church.
And when we read the scriptures and we have that image,
when Jesus Christ appeared to his disciples
without wonderful words, it says, please be with you.
As the Father has sent me. Jesus said,
I am sending you
le beloved brothers, we need you to come to Nicaragua.
We
Thank God for all these 25 years that had passed.
And
Now what we're gonna do, everybody just gonna go home
or doing our own business.
Oh, we're gonna say, just like the prophet said,
I am here, send me,
oh, when Paul, when he was first saw, when he was persecuting the church,
And
He has an personal encounter with Jesus,
I love what the puzzle Paul said,
Lord, what do you want me to do?
He didn't say, Lord,
what do you want the pastor or the elders or the leadership to do? He said,
Lord, what do you want me to do?
And I just would like to bring everything that I have said in this few,
in this few minutes
and to think that this celebration of 25 years that we have had of ministry,
that the next 25 years,
the next 25 years have to have four columns,
Four
Bases, where all these things is gonna be, uh, as a foundation.
The first one is to exalt and glorify the name of Jesus,
Jude
1 25, Jude 1 25
Salvador
To the only one and wise, our Lord Jesus,
Glory
Be the glory and majesty.
He's empire and powerful now and forever.
The Apostle Paul in one Timothy one 17 says, uh,
for to the king of kings,
I
Immortal and invisible to the only one.
And wise Gods
be honor and glory for the forever and ever.
The second column is being grateful.
You have to recognize that we are in the best company. Of all the times,
many things are going to happen
Like,
But the church of Jesus Christ is gonna stand forever.
That's
What he said.
The gates of hell will not prevail against the church of God.
And
The third column is lives that are consecrated to God.
The Apostle Paul said, with Christ, I am crucified.
It is not me that I live
Me,
But Christ lives in me.
And where I live in this flesh,
I live in the faith of God who love me.
And the fourth column,
Make
Yourself available to the purposes of God.
We need you.
We have that image of saying everything for the glory of God,
thankful to God because he gives the privilege to serve him
and consecrating our lies for the glory of God.
And with that attitude to go and do the work of God.
Brothers
And sisters,
we're gonna celebrate another 25 years and we're gonna base this on the presence
of God. Please be with you. Jesus said,
as the Father has sent me, I
See
That's the way I send you. Now what are you going to do?
Are you gonna go?
Are
You gonna stay? And some of you may not be able to go
Mission.
And we could say, we could pray for missions,
Missionaries, and
You may not be able to go, but you can pray for the missionaries.
We need pastors in mat.
Praise God for all the work that is being done in.
We need many pastors in many areas of, uh, of that part of Nicaragua,
and many of you cannot go, but you can give for the missions
and all that can go, all those courageous,
all Christians,
let's go and put the name of God above everything because there's no,
there's no greater name than the name of Jesus Christ.
Let's
Stand up and give thanks to God.